Hey, j'ai besoin de gâteau pour le père Noël!
C'est un bon feu.
Si il passe par là, on va bien lui cramer le cul.
Ce gros bâtard.
(Chanson «Jingle Bells»)
Hey, joyeux No...
Vous avez commencé sans nous!
Oh regarde Loulou, la petite vache.
Bonjour toi...
Mais qu'est ce que tu fais toute seul?
Mais que tu viens faire ici ? Tu devais passer la soirée chez Elton John!
Ahhh, mais pas du tout.
Mais pas du tout, je ne vois pas du tout pourquoi, pas du tout.
Très bien on se rassemble autour de l'arbre de noël...
ahahah
Hey, moi j'aime ça les cadeaux! Whou! Hey, moi j'aime ça avoir des cadeaux à Noël les papapoutes! Whaou!
(musique)
Pour sceller notre amitié je...
voulais te donner quelque chose
À moi?!
Je te donne hou je te donne je te donne
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est quoi?
c'est pas une chainette. C'est pas une gourmette
Qu'est-ce que c'est? aïe
Écoutez, de l'extérieur c'est... c'est magnifique.
Ooooh
Oooooh
Aaaah
Ça c'est ce qui s'appelle être gâté pourri à noël.
Regardez oui! Un gros bidet narguilé et cafetière qui fait aussi les pommes de terre frites
Ils sont forts ces Arabes.
Incassable, Incass...
cassé
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est?
C'est de la merde!
non non
c'est Kloug
(musique)
Un cadeau pour la reine des reines.
Le seul cadeau que je veux pour noël...
c'est toi!
(bruit d'une personne qui vomie)
Nan, Nan... C'est parce que... quand je suis content je vomis
et là Chuis hyper content!
Et c'est pour qui cette merveille de chocolat intense?
À moi?!
Tiens!
Attrape.
aoutch
Pas d'bras, pas d'chocolat.
(rire)
(musique)
C'est Noël, c'est Noël
Noëëëëëël
achète tes places
pour l'OlympiaaaaaAAAAA